[Musica]
ho pensato di iniziare mio discorso con
una frase di lewes brown che mi è sempre
piaciuta tantissimo perché racchiude in
maniera esaustiva mio percorso personale
e professionale punta 7 era l'una
male che vada avrei camminato tra le
stelle e che cosa rappresenta la luna
per me rappresenta quel mondo
irraggiungibile
direi l'ottavo quella voglia di andare
sempre oltre le cose di fare nuove
esperienze di raggiungere traguardi sia
dal punto di vista personale che
professionale in qualità di medico
oncologo e ricercatore serve però al
servizio di tutti qua listello
incontrato in questi anni tantissime
tutte molto belle che hanno lasciato un
segno indelebile lungo il mio cammino
oggi vorrei condividere con voi la mia
storia una storia fatta di sacrifici e
difficoltà di dedizione ed amore per il
proprio lavoro
direi che nel mio piccolo una storia di
fearless tutto iniziato in puglia
università specializzazione e dottorato
di ricerca ma in le stelle ne hanno
portato altrove e quindi sono dovuta
approdare in emilia romagna nel grande
centro oncologico dell'emilia romagna a
cui sono sempre molto grata e appena
arrivata dopo qualche mese ci fu un
meeting a cui partecipano tutti da
medici e biologi e biologi e ognuno di
noi fu chiesto la propria disponibilità
ad andare
all'estero per il periodo per accogliere
nuove collaborazioni internazionali
tutti prima di me anche più giovani
sorprendentemente rifiutarlo e per vari
motivi personali familiari o
semplicemente per timori
io con la mia caratteristica voglia di
fare sempre nuove esperienze di puntare
alla mia nonna e oggi dire anche con un
pizzico d'incoscienza di sì subito essi
mi mi fuoco data questa possibilità ma
mi fu detto di adoperarmi per trovare un
istituto in grado di accoglierli
io iniziai a cercare su internet i più
grandi istituti in quel momento nel
campo dell'oncologia e schizzi un'email
semplice ma allo stesso tempo molto
formale provenendo un po dalla mentalità
della gerarchia delle università
italiane al professore apart
all'istituto cancer research
mi rispose subito in maniera molto
contento e cortese dandomi la sua
disponibilità ad accogliermi nel suo
team ha fatto che avesse applicato ad un
bando di ricerca
io fui contemporaneamente molto felice
ma allo stesso tempo molto preoccupata
non avevo mai fatto esperienze
all'estero lavorative aveva una
conoscenza della lingua inglese base
proveniva dal liceo scientifico e non
avevo nessuna conoscenza all'estero ma
con la tenacia tipica di noi donne la
caparbietà del sud non mi sono mai
lasciato sopraffare dallo scoramento
pubblicare bando per la borsa europea di
oncologia
ogni settimana più o meno il mio capo in
di quello che sarebbe stato il mio
futuro capelli se mi mandava le sue
collezioni
i suoi suggerimenti di cui ho capito
naturalmente prima il 25 per cento a
causa delle barriere linguistiche ma con
l'arma dino sempre ferma la volontà di
applicare a questo bando e del mare
fuori d'italia ea giugno 2014 avuto la
notifica di aver vinto la borsa europea
di oncologia esmo traslazionale e ha
detto per unire 14 sono approdata a
londra il mio progetto di ricerca si
basa sullo studio del dna più morale
circolate nel carcinoma prostatico
immaginati a quei tempi una donna che si
affacciano i tumori urologici e con un
progetto di ricerca sul dna tumorale
circolante che a quei tempi
rappresentava un po la novità nel campo
scientifico
il dna tumorale circolante rappresenta
la frazione di dna che viene rilasciata
dalle cellule tumorali nel sangue e che
ci permette di analizzare il patrimonio
genetico dei pazienti né verificando un
pò quelle molecole in grado di predire
la risposta ai trattamenti i fan di
darci i fattori prognostici di
stratificare i pazienti per i
trattamenti iniziate si trovare una
parola in grado di racchiudere un po
quello che è stato il mio percorso di
ricerche tuttora compagna la mia ricerca
e sicuramente biomarcatore cioè lo
studio di un marker a livello
del sangue di questi pazienti in grado
di personalizzare in un certo senso il
trattamento in oncologia e quindi con il
mio diciamo quell oggetto di ricerca
arrivai a londra dove 2014 e arrivare
appena arrivata naturalmente lasciare il
sole l'azzurro del cielo e che mi fanno
e per trovare il grigio del cielo
inglese con la classica le gemelline di
londra che si insegna a portarti
l'ombrello ma che tanto non serve perché
ti parli lo stesso lavorare con
tantissimi ragazzi di tutte le
nazionalità in un ambiente altamente
competitivo e di imparare a sequenziare
il dna quindi per me tutto era nuovo
tutela era difficile e dopo il primo
anno con la mia innata voglia di puntare
sempre alla luna ho chiesto la
possibilità di prolungare la mia borsa
europea che vi fu accordata dal mio
spedale italiano è sicuramente dal team
inglese quindi rimasi un altro ammalò
proseguendo la mia ricerca del
biomarcatore circolante nel carcinoma
prostatico
ma in un setting di malattia più precoce
ovvero prima della chemioterapia
quando facevamo in abiti invece
l'incontro di tutti i componenti della
più o meno ogni settimana ognuno
presentare i propri dati
il mio progetto fu definito un crisi
project avere un progetto folle pazzo
che non volessero dire inutile perché
all'inizio i dati ottenuti non erano
sicuramente buoni il mio progetto non
decollava ea un certo punto il mio post
inglese mi chiamò e mi disse che voleva
interrompere il progetto perché era solo
un dispendio di energie di soldi io
tenacemente i sì di proseguire ancora
per un pochino perché credevo in quel
progetto
alla fine un giorno in nell'incredulità
di tutti le curve di sopravvivenza dei
miei pazienti non erano più
sovrapponibili ma si dividevano in base
alla presenza del mio biomarcatore il
mio crisi project di venerdì great
project il mio biomarcatore
probabilmente serve un sento in diverso
agiva più lentamente ma funzionava
a quel punto arrivarono tantissimi
campioni dall'italia
arrivarono campioni dall'inghilterra e
ben diciotto istituti spagnoli vogliono
collaborare con noi il costituendo la
nostra corte di valutazione e analizza
oltre 300 pazienti correlando i dati
molecolari con quelli mici i risultati
furono presentati al congresso
internazionale di oncologia che mi nasco
che usiamo si tiene a chicago e non
riuscì ad ottenere anche lui
world che rappresenta il maggior
riconoscimento per un ricercatore in
oncologia che ogni anno viene consegnato
a chicago e quel progetto di ricerca
però continuo perché arrivato risultati
brillanti prosegue quindi con le
collaborazioni già installate ecosistemi
il secondo merita world potrei dire che
quindi la fortuna e la tenacia sono
state ottime compagne lungo il mio
cammino associato naturalmente la
caparbietà tipica di noah donne ma non
era finita qui volevo continuare a
puntare alla mia luna e contrari ancora
stelle bellissime sul mio cammino e
quindi lasciare l'europa per provare
l'esperienza oltreoceano per provare se
veramente quel sogno definito americano
e quel sogno americano era veramente un
sogno o era soltanto una meteora arriva
lì quindi a new york il 30 dicembre 2017
tra in una panchina tempesta di neve e
rimase bloccata a quattro giorni a casa
e questa una delle tante di peste che
dovette incontrare nel corso di quegli
anni da new york e boston e quindi i
nomi tuatha la corsa ai supermercati per
fare la spesa al i messaggi che
arrivavano sul cellulare e per
avvertirci dell'arrivo dello storm o
alla polizia che girava perché poteva
potevano circolare solo le persone con
motivi
ma soprattutto ricordo di quegli anni i
tanti colleghi che sono andati via
perché magari il progetto non aveva dato
i risultati sperati e che quindi dopo un
meeting prepararono i classici scatoloni
contenenti le loro cose andavano via non
vi dico che quel periodo c'era la paura
di deludere gli ospedali italiano il mio
team inglese e collaboratori che ha
letti e famiglia arenti amici proprio
perché la il timore di dover andare via
da un momento all'altro anch'io lavorano
da lunedì a lunedì successivo quindi
sempre ritmi incalzanti ambiente
altamente competitivo altri altri studi
altri pazienti da analizzare sempre alla
ricerca di biomarcatori nel carcinoma
prostatico
e così arriva il terzo merita un word
immaginate con grande gioia e oggi
qualcuno mi può chiedere ma davvero
quello è stato un sogno americano per te
io risponderei sì lo stato come per
morti perché mi ha messo di fronte alla
grandezza e alla piccola insensibile
alla grandezza di una società che
investe nella ricerca
e alla piccolezza dei propri limiti c'è
al sentirsi a volte proprio inadeguato
non all'altezza in un ambiente
estremamente competitivo quindi diciamo
che l'invito oggi ea non lasciarsi mai
scoraggiare soprattutto i più giovani e
non lasciarsi cullare un po da quella
che la routine ma anzi di tentare sempre
nuovi traguardi e anche in un periodo
difficile
l'incognita come questo per me oggi ci a
parlare qui a voi giovani e non giovani
di ricerca scientifica 360 gradi e un
grande successo è un grande traguardo
perché significa un po cercare di
avvicinare tutti ad un mondo così
misterioso quale quello della ricerca e
allo stesso tempo comunque che da lungo
potrebbe dare la possibilità di
camminare tra le stelle più belle
tornando alle sfide però non erano
finite perché settembre 2019 c'è stato
il mio rientro in italia dopo oltre
cinque anni all'estero alcuni direbbero
che forse questa è stata la sfida più
grande dopo aver camminato per le stelle
più belle sul palcoscenico
dell'oncologia internazionale di entrare
in un paese che sicuramente in cui
sicuramente la ricerca non ha presenta
un attualità e qui ancora troppo poche
donne rivestono posizioni dirigenziali
mi ricordo di ciò però diciamo che la
paura poi man mano ha lasciato il posto
alla speranza di portare proprio
bagaglio
personale professionale nel proprio
paese li di tokyo e proprio ai giovani
soprattutto le giovani donne di non
lasciarsi mai scoraggiare di non
rimanere mai incatenate nei certi skill
i prototipi ma nel cercare di puntare
sempre alla propria luna con l'energia
all'intuizione della capacità
organizzativa che contraddistingue
sempre non idoneo oggi oltre 60 per
cento del personale che lavora in
laboratorio in ospedale rappresentato da
donne
e questa percentuale tenderà ad
aumentare nei diavoli
quindi questo ci fa capire come le donne
con coraggio dobbiamo imparare a
riunirci a fare gruppo a condividere i
propri progetti e sicuramente cercando
quantomeno di raggiungere le posizioni
di responsabilità anche degli uomini
per quanto riguarda il fearless della
mia ricerca cioè la mia luna quale è
sempre quella di cercare di trovare un
biomarcatore una molecola in grado come
detto prima di personalizzare i
trattamenti cioè di dare la terapia
giusta per il giusto paziente oncologico
evitando tossicità gli utili e cercando
lady a migliorare nella sopravvivenza in
maniera statisticamente significativa
come dico sempre io
non c'è nessun traguardo è importante se
non è per tutti se non è per il bene di
tutti e oggi tante persone come me
sicuramente in più di me lavorano
costantemente
contatta sacrificio nei laboratori di
ricerca cercando di raggiungere
traguardi che sono al servizio della
sofferenza di tutti
a volte molti ricercatori non sono
remunerate ricevono delle minime borse
di studio e questo è bene da sapere
perché dietro brevi soddisfazione se
c'erano tanti sacrifici e parte e tante
difficoltà e soprattutto oggi al tempo
d'oggi e vede che non ci lasciamo
travolgere da quelle che sono le idee
che vanno di moda di complottismo di
negazionismo di business farmaceutico ma
dobbiamo stare vicino a tutti i nostri
ricercatori perché i loro traguardi sono
i traguardi sicuramente di tutti per
quanto riguarda me come ho detto di
stelle lo incontrate tante lungo il mio
cammino e archiviarlo mi hanno
illuminato e spero che continuino ad
illuminare e riscaldare soprattutto in
questo periodo di buio di oscurità in
piena pandemia e non solo il mio cammino
ma il cammino di tutti coloro che
incontrerò nei laboratori di ricerca e
di nudo particolare lungo le corsie di
ospedale
grazie